he's uh a two-time world series champ of
the reds and uh two-time
national league mvp he's a hall of famer
the greatest catcher ever
johnny bench joining us on the program
and johnny is going to be auctioning off
his personal collection of hall of fame
items and uh he's auctioning off
everything but his hall of fame ring
he'll be using the auction proceeds to
help his uh three young sons with their
education
hunt auctions.com for more information
johnny joins us now what should i buy
johnny ooh
ooh okay no i mean
like everything is going i mean this is
the uh legends ring
let's see okay i got this one here we go
there we go
okay that's a legends ring living legend
all right
when i die you can have it
hall of famer in hand
the bob euker bobblehead the harry doyle
bobblehead
harriet signed by harry doyle himself
now that's off limits
that totally are you serious would you
sell any of your stuff right there in
front of you
no i would not no i would not uh why now
uh
i don't know my we've been trying to
plan and everything else i've got uh 14
year old and 11 year old sons
sooner or later college is going to be
coming up they're going to be wanting to
be going to certain colleges and certain
opportunities that kind of come to them
and
you know i i got my oldest son through
boston university
at uh at in a great expense and
uh i made 2.2 million in my entire
career
so you know that uh that's about two
weeks worth of work now in the major
leagues
and i uh i you know you you need the
money to do it and you want them the
best for them
and so many people tell stories about
and i don't know bob gibson was talking
about his
at one time his his family was arguing
over we've got what who got i want that
no i want this and then
i've had just friends of mine call and
said i can tell you the drama that goes
on
that uh when somebody tries to divide
something up
whether it be antiques whether it be art
whether it be no mom want me to have
that and then
i've had families that are destroyed
they're you know they're separated
they're do it but
i want them to have a great opportunity
and let's face it where
where are all those you know some of
it's been in the museum in bangor
but a lot of it's in boxes and safe
deposit boxes and
and it's a good opportunity for me we've
been exploring it for a while
it's been a thought and uh i think it's
gonna be a great opportunity to provide
them with the future
what will be the toughest item to part
with
well some of those i've kept i mean you
know i mean like my larry bird
basketball you know signed to me you
know larry bird same birthday same day
now
i guess um probably the mvp trophies
the mvp trophies uh and i got a solder
oh
oh bat do you have any of those no i do
not i have about i have the only bad i
believe
i'm pretty sure in existence signed by
the all-century team
that is in my possession so i
you know it's it's the rings it's the
hall of fame plaques and stuff
kept my thurman monster award i kept my
hutch award i wanted
because you know they made it mean a lot
and i didn't want to put them in there
and
there's a lot of great stuff in there
but uh you know
how do you how do you always pick but
the boy's decision was
they they didn't argue over the rings
they weren't very
worried about it and so this a better
opportunity for me and
and it seems like in a down year that uh
it might not be the best time but
you know auctions have done well and and
uh people are interested i saw the vin
scully auction i don't know if you did
yeah
kelly auction was was huge and a lot of
people out there would like to have
something and i had friends called said
they're bidding on stuff that i never
even thought
you know would even consider that so how
much is a gold glove going to cost me
depends on the year strangely enough uh
the year
i guess coincides with if i won an mvp
or i was rookie of the year or something
somewhere that's what they're saying
it's probably going to cost you anywhere
from 25 to 50.
which is you know you know a couple days
work that is
that is now that the peacock has come
along yes that's true
um there's also uh the painting by leroy
neiman
yes famous leroy neiman painting there i
think there's a reserve on that
50. 50k and you have quite a collection
of leroy humans from what i hear
i have i have a couple of them in here
yeah absolutely but they're nudes of me
hey how about an even trade i'll give
you a nude leroy neiman
for the leroy neiman of you all right
it's fair i don't need a nude leroy
lehmann of him
no no it's me i it's it's me nude by
leroy neiman
without the danettes right no no they're
not
but if i walk into your house how long
does it take before i realize
what you do for a living uh
this is the office that my son put
together
okay there's a lot of stuff
so i mean you know i do a lot of stuff
with hope for the warriors
i do uh some charity work obviously
here's a here's a cool thing bob hope uh
when i went with him
and then the airborne this is pretty
cool this is a roast uh
the johnny bench roast bob hope was the
emcee that's all we could get that day
uh the old century team how about this
one
now this is really cool my my assistant
got this sign for me i hope it's not a
reflection
but this is me on the steps of
cooperstown right outside the back
yeah they're all of the hall of famers
in a tidmouth and my assistant got them
all to sign it
how many hall of famers you got there
i'm going to say
40 35 to 40.
who was the best storyteller when you
guys got together at the hall of fame
you know strangely enough uh
i'd love to listen to george brett
george he's one of my favorite people
like he's one of my favorite people
george is a stud man and he he always
laughs when he tells the story
but he remembers that he's so did
but it's so vivid you know and
everything's still in where they did it
and you know you know different people
see things in different ways they never
you see this and they see it differently
and they they pull it out and they
they stretch it out and everything else
i mean
there was nothing like doing that now i
love this you know strangely enough
i don't know if it's strange gaylord
perry
sits in the lobby of the ota saga hotel
and i sit there and listen to the
stories
and just roar because he you know the
things that he does and the in the
positions and everything else
it's it's really cool you know and fun
fun is the new guys you know pedro
martinez
and the big hurt man there there's some
fun stuff and it
i'm going to need a lot of fun coming up
after the pass but
as fast did you care if a pitcher was
loading up a pitch like gaylord perry
threw a spit ball you know nolan ryan is
alleged to have cut the ball
or you know somebody would doctor the
ball what
did you care if that if a pitcher was
doing that
well uh i would just say so if i knew
they had it loaded i would look for it
and then i could
then if i waited for the drop to hit it
but i don't know if you ever told your
story about jim maloney was
decided he was going to load him up he
said john we're going to load them up
i think i'm going to load some up
because this is when phil reagan and
and uh william and gaylord were you know
loading them up
he says he said i think we better have a
sign i said you throw it i'll catch it
well two strikes two outs first in the
first inning he throws one
i don't touch it hits me right on top of
the toe
second inning two outs two strikes he
throws it again hits me on top of the
shin guard and bounces back to him
and i walked out and i said we're gonna
have to have a signal
i never took my eyes off of him again
ever how do you load it up though how do
you load it up
well it's just a little vaseline behind
the ear okay you know gaylord used to do
when they told him he couldn't do it
anymore he would take his thumb
on his brow up here and so he never
looked well he didn't touch his fingers
he just loaded right there and then when
he put it back down he just put his
fingers on it
right here so i never took my eyes off
it we're in forbes field
and somebody in the dugout the manager
hollered at me and i looked in the
dugout
and then i thought oh did he load did he
give me the sign
he threw this thing it started here and
it dropped so hard i barely caught
leather on it right there
hit me in the cup broke it in seven
places and that was the last time
needless to say that he ever loaded it
up so
he's uh johnny bench you can check out
all the auction items from his hall of
fame career
it uh you can see everything on display
at hunt
auctions.com for information i did think
about you the other night when i'm
watching the world series
and when kevin cash goes out to take out
blake snell
and i wondered what role the catcher can
play there
now you were established you were one of
the better players best players in the
game
can you do you think the catcher could
have played a role to say look
he's still got bite he's got velocity
these guys aren't
catching up to anything because he went
out with the predetermined
all right you gave up a hit mookie's up
i'm taking you out like there was no
wiggle room there
yeah that was the match-up and that was
the hardest thing to describe but it was
it was mookie i don't
any other player any other batter i
don't think he takes him out
i think the analytics are so big a part
of this game right now that that's a
commitment to do it
but it has to be a thing and i some
managers like sparky never wanted the
pitcher to lose a game they never wanted
him to be the losing pitcher if he
pitched that well
i had such a rapport with sparky that i
would look over in the dugout
and he knew when i looked at him that he
needed to get somebody warmed up
i would come in off the field i said get
somebody up and we could do that
um i think there's a the analytics are
there
and it's very it's buried in the game
now it's it's embedded and
i think it's going to do it you know mr
cash is going to you know
listen to it like every manager and
everybody's going to second guess and
but it was mookie i mean let's face it i
mean any other batter probably in
baseball at this time he probably
wouldn't have taken him out but
it was a situation where everything
dictated
my dictation would have been had me if i
were catching
is that i will pitch around mookie
because they've gotten him out they
struck him out a couple of times and
they got him to ground balls a couple
things
i would have pitched around him and hope
that mookie being anxious in that
situation now he's got a great eye but
you try to get them to chase a pitch
that they normally wouldn't go after and
i i thought it was a tough decision
snell didn't want to come out i mean he
had him he was at where he wanted to be
and
uh that was the decision that sometime
the organization makes by making
analytics the most important thing
before i let you go i know it's been a
tough couple of weeks you lost joe
morgan
and uh you know i'm i'm trying to
capture joe morgan to let
you know a new generation know just how
special he was because
he did everything and you don't see a
guy that size
who is you know power hitter he was a
gold glove winner
two-time mvp the spark for that team
and if you do you have a favorite story
of of joe
the thing about joe was he his favorite
favorite player was nellie fox so he's
five foot seven five foot seven
and he and nellie became a a mentor of
his actually when he went to houston and
and joe uh how about this step
four years four seasons joe morgan had
50 or more extra base hits
50 stolen bases and 100 base on balls
four seasons wow in the history of
baseball
in the history of baseball no one has
ever done it one season
you know um wow he
he was the kind of guy and if an
infielder ever
no infielder is supposed to talk to the
pitcher i didn't i nothing
they weren't they didn't know what to
say didn't know what to do but if joe
morgan came in from second base to talk
to the pitcher i stayed behind the play
wow because i mean he we seem to be on
the same vibe i mean our
we i think sometimes we were just you
know
brothers at one time in our lives and in
spiritual and middle and
and he was he knew the game he
understood i knew the game
and and it was the best player i ever
saw i mean
like you said how can you be a gold
glove steal bases hit home runs if your
games on the line
take the red sox 1975. who do you want
it to play
joe morgan who got the base hit joe
murray
and um i uh i
as i told his what his wife you know i
said teresa i said you know
we are so fortunate to have had him in
our lives
um you know some people never get
experienced the greatness
and the friendship and the love that
that people can have for each other so
it yeah it's been tough i'm telling you
you know joe tom and
and all the others now kaylin was such a
dear man i mean so i appreciate you
today i mean give me an opportunity to
talk about him man
he he was uh he was the heart and soul
and i try to tell people
you know bob gibson like i was nervous
and i was just watching a game when he
would be on the mound i can't imagine
what it was like to face gibson
alkaline is a one of the true gentlemen
in in in life not in just baseball i
mean
we've lost you know some great great
people not just great players
yeah lou brock uh i i came in to se i
came into st
louis he had 32 stolen bases in a row
and we have jack fisher pitching
we call him fat jack fisher because he
had a belly and he rested his glove on
it
he dressed his glove right here and he
was pretty quick to home plate well
loose stole took off the steel and i
threw it down and lou hadn't got to the
cutout
he hadn't even started to slide and got
to the dirt
and you know after the game i'm sitting
in my locker
and and uh one of those shopping carts
pull up in front of my locker well
that's where we put our dirty sweats and
everything else
and one rule was you never fraternize it
cost us fifty dollars if we talk to
another player
dave bristol was just so adamant about
you not fraternizing
well this cart's still sitting there i
look up it's lou brock
he's in uniform in our locker room and
i'm next to the manager's office
he looked down at me and he said next
time kid make it look close
uh so the auction hunt auctions.com all
the great stuff that uh
johnny has available for everybody and
that'll be november 14th
november 14th at hunt auctions.com
great to see you and uh yeah it's going
to be live in louisville kentucky at the
uh
at the louisville slugger museum of
where i'm alleging
living of course you are yeah just don't
die
because then you're no longer a living
legend i haven't thought of that
although i am standing over here with
mays kofax and aaron
is the living legend so it's pretty good
how often did you face kofax
never he retired in 66.
and your first year was 68
i came up the end of 67. 67. when i was
19. now lucky for you you didn't have to
face kofax
oh i owned him you would have right
you would i'm sure thank you bud
all right bro that's uh johnny bench
hall of famer